Speaker 1: We have a voicemail.
No, that number is two one nine two.
David, P..
Here's a caller who wants some clarity on
Yiddish and Jewish words.
So of course, when people need clarity on
that, I guess they call me.
Speaker 5: Hi, David.
I'm from Alabama.
OK.
And this is a genuine question.
I just don't think many Jewish people pardon
my ignorance, but I hear the term Schmeichel
sometimes and.
Does that mean penis or money?
OK.
I'm not trolling here, I'm seriously asking
because sometimes I hear in the context of,
okay, they're definitely talking about their
phallic region, but I just don't know, man.
Speaker 1: OK, so here's the deal.
There's two similar sounding words.
The words are Schmeichel and shekel.
OK, Schmeichel means little penis in Yiddish.
Schmeichel shekel means money.
Shekels were silver coins used in ancient
Israel and the Middle East.
It's now the currency of Israel.
The new Israeli shekel, the latter shekel,
is sometimes used anti-Semitic.
So, for example, you have to.
These are often dog whistles, so you have
to understand the context when you see like
these right wingers go, you know, all of these
heads of media outlets and film studios hoarding
their shekels.
When they say that, they're saying these Jewish
CEOs hoarding money.
So sometimes shekel is used as a dog whistle.
It is the new Israeli shekel, the current
currency in the State of Israel.
All right.
So hopefully that is illuminating on the bonus
show today.
Are there going to be presidential debates
in 2024?
Maybe not.
And we'll tell you why there is an Austin,
Texas, basic income program that's going to
give struggling residents a thousand dollars
a month, and there are concerns about Senator
Dianne Feinstein.
I'll tell you what those concerns are.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Sign up at join Packman dot com to get instant
access.
Unidentified: I will see you that.